I started using column to build Android
apps before I joined Google Kotlin
allows you to express the same ideas in
your app using less lines of code the
more you use the language the more you
unlock its power and the more fun it
becomes to use as a result Google
supporting column as another programming
language for Android because we want to
do what's best for developers supporting
another programming language is a ton of
work but we feel it's the right thing to
do for the community my name is Dan Kim
and I'm an Android programmer here at
Basecamp in Chicago I had been writing
Java for many many years and in February
issue of 2016 at Basecamp we decided to
take a deeper look at Colin Colin was
different Colin felt like it was
exciting it was fun it like made us much
happier to work with when we heard the
announcement at Google i/o that Colin
was gonna be a first class language we
were super excited we knew that that
meant for us better support for the
tooling and everything was kind of
getting it better for cob
first and foremost both times they were
absolutely insane when we first started
using it it was to the point where we
decided to port our entire build system
it's been really fun to see how all of
those pain points early on have kind of
dissipated and now the build times are
something that we don't even have to
talk about or argue about with a bunch
of other developers one of the things
that we were surprised about is how easy
it is to quantify Colin's benefit to our
code base one of the things that one of
my co-workers did was pull a graph of
the different high priority issues filed
against the feature as he slowly
migrated it from fully Java to fully
college we would get to the status quo
of zero most months and then maybe there
were some abnormal months where you
would have one serious issue and so that
graph just kind of bottomed out a much
more stable codebase there's been two
key improvements one is the a broader
support and use of Kotlin in the
development community means that there's
many more resources libraries tools even
articles being written that help us to
learn more and get better and faster
using Catlin and Expedia has helped us
to write more succinct and easier to
read code it also helps make our
developers a lot have
now that the language is stabilized well
much happier using cotton for what we do
it's also helped guide us into writing
better code and making sure we're
avoiding null pointer problems the one
thing that we can measure is that the
code is certainly more concise and clear
and so we're writing less code overall
so I would say that we write somewhere
between 15 to 25 percent less code
overall than we would with Java the
biggest thing is that it's made us
really happy toward it it's really fun
and interesting exciting to work with it
and it's just not something we've ever
felt with other languages and I've
certainly never felt that with another
language it's exciting to see how
quickly the developer community has been
adopting common we're just starting to
realize its full potential on Android we
look forward to continuing to work with
both JetBrains and you all to realize
its full potential on Android
[Music]